[Music]
what's up you guys we're back with
another live stream but this time we're
on the academy channel because we're
going to talk about
design i have an amazing guest that's
lined up and ready to talk to us
but just for one second i want to say
what's up donuts futurists
futurati future fam we got stefan koontz
on the show with us today and if you
don't know who he is you will know him
in one second there's a good chance
you're already following him on
instagram he's a letterer designer
illustrator typographer
he's got this signature style that he
calls typo x
photo we'll talk about that in a little
bit in a term that he's using called
wordscapes
hand lettering art integrated into
unique
landscapes and his his about page needs
to be updated because
last check he's got 379 000 plus
followers on instagram oh my god
beast mode right there he's worked with
asics adobe and apple those are just the
a's okay
coca-cola unsplash nokia hallmark
microsoft a ton of other people
he's born in zurich and he may be
returning there soon but he's based out
of australia
right now if you guys go check out his
instagram it's stefan koons
k-u-n-z you can check out all his work
he posts very frequently and you can see
all this wonderful
hand-lettered goodness here's some of
his work
i believe this is and we'll find out
from stefan in a second
in his home and i see these things and
i'm just imagining to myself
he erases them and then does it does
another one
and that like when we have one of these
things made we leave it up for years
and he's just tearing it down to do
another one right matthew you know what
i'm talking about
our chocolate made by five interns
so this is part of his word scapes doing
his hand lettering in environments
wow i hope this is your notebook stefan
but we'll find out in
the internet sometimes could lead you
wrong and this is gonna
speak directly to mr ben burns but first
coffee
and then create something today even if
it sucks
and he has a book out you guys and we'll
talk about that in a little bit
so now you guys must be falling in love
with stefan
he's young i am he's talented he's
good-looking
he's prolific he's got a big social
following what is there not to like
about this guy
let's try and find something we can hate
on we'll work on that right
he also makes tools for creative people
brushes look at this
for procreate that's simulate
paint markers that's pretty cool it is
very legit
so you know what instead of just us
looking at static images why don't we
watch the video jonah hey legends
welcome to my youtube channel
if you want to see a little bit more of
this
for this
[Music]
why don't you hit that subscribe button
so you won't miss what's coming up
what happened there so without further
ado staphon welcome to the show
there he is god i just don't like you
already
it's just not like you got the good hair
he's young he's talented he's making
money you're doing big things in the
world
welcome to the show how you doing man
thank you chris
good i'm good i'm sitting here in the
morning in australia with my morning
coffee
and uh gotta say there's nothing better
to do than to talk to you on a rainy day
you know you look super chill right now
you're like relaxed and you got the big
comfy chair
and you got the nice mic
funny story my chair is being sold in
a couple of hours so somebody is going
to pick it up in a couple of hours
and then i won't have it so i'm enjoying
that last time
in that beautiful comfortable chair with
you
why are you selling your chair because i
i'm leaving the country
uh in about a week and so everything has
to go
and i hate selling stuff i hate taking
care of that
but you know it's all the good and
the thing that you have to get when you
go like when you get to the next
location
find everything else and so i'm selling
everything
wow okay so what brought you to
australia where abouts in australia are
you
i'm in sydney australia it's uh the east
coast
and uh where the sun goes up and i
i've been here like six years before and
i felt that was the right time to
to move or to go there um i've been here
like on on visits only so i've not been
working from here but just been
been traveling around and yeah it helped
definitely get my
mileage status a lot faster because you
travel like 15 hours to the us
or 24 hours to europe so do you travel a
lot
i do i do a lot of um i love doing like
commission pieces commission work
and and so i get to travel a lot all
around
doing conferences doing um doing live
art so for for example i've been in
sweden
well switzerland as well um in the
states
and and all around just doing pieces
everywhere
i can and i love traveling as well
are big clients hiring you to do murals
for them is that what we're talking
about here
um all kinds of from from workshops to
um to murals to like individual pieces
um and i've been getting into two murals
more so
what you are wanting to do more like
that's kind of what you should focus on
on getting and and so with with the
chalk art that i do
people see that i do large scale things
even if it has nothing to do with murals
and they see large scale and they
translate that to oh this
actually could cool on our wall and and
since what i love to do is encouraging
people and through
my instagram posts um they often
come out to me and ask me to do the same
thing for them
i see i got a lot of questions for you i
just want to make sure everybody is
watching live on youtube
get your comments in matthew's joining
us for this live stream
he'll be monitoring your questions and
asking it at the appropriate time there
he is with his double eyebrow pump
the glass classic now i got a question
for you so there's probably a lot of
people in our audience who
really admire the kinds of things you do
even if they don't know who you are
it's a dream i mean what you do looks
really beautiful it's very engaging
so let's just talk a bit about business
a little bit how do you make a living
doing what it is that you do so if we
look back on 2018
either in percentages or however you
want to talk about whatever you're
comfortable with how do you make a
living where does the money come from
and give us a sense of the scope and
scale and the kinds of things you do
please
all right so um last year
i've i've had like five different income
streams okay and number one
was uh actually the shop it overtook
what i did with uh with supply work and
client work was basically um
maybe 40 40. and then the rest is
is like speaking engagements instagram
posts
so paid promotions um and what else
um and now like something that i started
new is like coaching sessions it's
something that i just
like it's not money that i'm i'm i'm
doing that it's more about
like how can i help people and how can i
do it and
time is valuable so and as you know like
you want to charge people
so they also feel the value of what
they're getting um because if it's free
advice it's free advice it has no value
or not the same value and and so that's
kind of where
kind of like going with the knowledge
the consulting knowledge of
of even how to ramp up your instagram
business how to
how to promote something better i see
that usually uh companies come to me
with with an ask
for maybe to promote something and they
just want to get like a feed post or
instagram story and they kind of forget
that
um i actually like if they tell me what
they want or what they want to achieve
i'd love to help them more achieve that
goal instead of just
well you just pay for a feed post or
instagram post
instagram story post but yeah so
so that's kind of something that's
ramping up new but definitely last year
was client work um it was
the the shop and and then just
yeah some paid promotions uh speaking
engagements and
workshops beautiful so you said that now
what's that i also said do online
courses i i didn't there was nothing new
coming out last year but i
recorded one last year and it's coming
out uh this
following month it's all about social
media and how to grow on social media or
build up your presence on social media
perfect because i want to ask you about
that too
so i don't know how comfortable you are
and i'm i can't beat me if i
on the channel that talks about the
business of design and speaking to
artists
i'm just curious when you do client work
what is it and what are the general
ballpark ranges of prices that you would
charge to like if i wanted to hire stuff
on to do something for me
what kind of assignment would it be and
how much would you
in the ballpark of like what would you
charge
yeah so i said myself um
a floor number that i just i don't do
below so
at the point is around two thousand
eight hundred three thousand dollars
that's where i i'll start considering a
project
okay uh and and it can be a poster it
can be something easy so
so usually i don't do small stuff i
don't do the quick
uh stuff where people just say like oh i
want a quick logo or i want to
i don't know a a just a sign like it
will take you like 10 minutes i know
it will take me 10 minutes or five
minutes even but
i'm starting at that price point if you
want that at that price point
i'm happy to give that to you right so
that's kind of how i structured it and
then
it it develops over um to
like if it's a big company it's like
usage rights and that's kind of how you
can you can talk about your pricing
further so
say for example if if i'm doing
something for
microsoft and and they want to to
promote it
but they just don't want to keep it in
one country they want to sell it in
other countries as well
then you can go in and like all right
well you want probably the usage right
for all of these countries
and so on and like
pricing last year went everything from
from like 2k uh to what was
probably the biggest number that i had
was like 45 wow
50 000 thousand four projects which was
it was a campaign a key visual for for
the airport
um that was the biggest client project
that i've done
and and it was special because it's also
i i did it through
like i did it one two one so i had no
agents um
in in between i had no agency
um that that looked through the whole
thing and
and yes so it's it's directly
b to c or b2b like my business to their
business right
so you did a campaign at the airport is
this a like a live painting a mural that
you painted
so what i did they they came to me and
they asked me for
a um a visual campaign for their summer
uh campaign
and and then suddenly it turned into
not just being a visual but like it's
it's um
it will be over everything like they had
like mega poster
like like over when you're driving to to
the parking lot there's like a
massive poster uh it's the biggest size
i've ever seen my work on
and and then they had inside they had on
on pretty much everything from
from aprons that the chefs were cooking
in in the restaurants they
had like the the visual um and it just
said like best of switzerland with kind
of a gray background and
it all like typescape so it's it's uh
it's actually the matterhorn
um but written with every kind of word
that describes
switzerland or what's best it's just
like chocolate
cheese and all these things and and my
brother actually helped me with his
company
to to visualize that in in the video
form so he animated everything
um or had everything animated and that
was playing in the duty-free stores
um you could see like uh like
stands and booths everywhere in the
airport and that work was pretty much
everywhere
even in the newspaper that they
distribute on on swiss airlines
um there was this the the airport the
client contacted you directly or is
there an agency who found you and said
we would like for you to do this for us
so that was that was a funny story it's
uh somebody
just reach out to me and send me an
email through my website and like the
the form that i i get people just
to to submit to and and they just reach
out and
just say like we i have someone who
recommended you to
us and and there was something special
because
she didn't have a supervisor at the time
so she was responsible but
didn't have a supervising role um and
in their own marketing department and so
she was young
and she was willing to to to go for
something
creative kind of better um and
what i didn't know about was that she
had to sell that to her
superiors like one level above them
and who would approve the project and so
when i pitched it
she kind of came back to me a couple of
times just because she liked what i did
and she wanted
that to to be the campaign um so i
wasn't
they like big companies have to pitch
have
other companies to pitch in as well just
so they can make a selection even if
they like you really
right uh much and and so i had
to pitch against two agencies um
and again i've never done that before i
was like i had this stupid uh
confidence of yes i can do this i i'm
totally ready for
this job but while i was really not
prepared at all
and once i got the project and once we
started i was like really
seeing that i was totally out of my
death because like an agency would have
project managers have
people that will actually like know like
create the content creative directors
designers and all this team
and i was just like everything myself
and i had to come up with
with what i was about to do or how to
come up with all these
things myself and luckily enough she
um the the woman from her name is ava
she um she was smart enough to to see
that i was struggling a bit and and so
she helped me
through that process um make it happen
so together we were actually
an amazing team and even um
while i was here in australia we had
like time zone differences
um and so communicating was hard with
the between eight and ten hour time
difference
um so what was great about that was
actually that i could work through the
night
send them everything over and then in
the morning she had everything she could
work through it
uh get it um approved or not and then
send it back so when
we were on a time crunch we just made
that happen and made it
happen fast well i got it pretty much
because somebody recommended me
to her and she didn't follow me like
they didn't care about my instagram they
didn't care about
what i did there so i was like i was on
their impression like hey i'm big on
instagram so that's kind of why
it's kind of a foolish thing to do like
basing your um
your value on your numbers and and what
i learned
is is yeah i definitely didn't have
anything to do and when i pitched like
hey i can do
a live drawing they're like yeah well we
cannot pay you for this like but i'm i
have this huge following it's like
yeah that's not why we actually hired
you
you love your style and and all that
like the airport is
is a big company it's it's it's a
well-known company here in switzerland
and and so if if you were a respected
artist
that's kind of how she phrased it
nothing hurtful intended but it was just
it was for me it was the awakening of
like oh you know what i don't
i need to take myself less serious and
less um take myself on
like i'm i'm a like a beginner artist
i'm i'm still going into it i've i've
been doing this for maybe three four
years like business-wise i've been doing
this for three years
um it took off in 2017 so
not even that long and and so that's
you you realize you don't have to to
take yourself too seriously sometimes
yeah it sounded like in your telling of
the story
there was like perfect synchronicity
happening on your behalf despite
yourself
this young girl and if she was more
senior maybe it would have worked out
and she connected with you for a number
of different reasons and she helped you
along the process
you were in like you said out of your
depth or out of your league or whatever
because there were agencies pitching or
bidding against you and you didn't even
know how to do that and then you land
the largest job of your career so far as
as far as commission is concerned
i mean that's just that's an amazing
story and it seems like you
you've got the right perspective and you
learn so much from this experience to
say like
yes in some some areas i need to grow
some areas and some areas i just
need to realize i'm just beginning on my
creative journey despite the fact that i
had this large internet following right
because prior to that i'm pretty sure
most people find you
because of your large following you're
like yeah i'm that guy yeah i gotcha
and then they're like who no we just
like your work and this is a big deal so
we can't be messing around with live
drawings and all that kind of stuff
so that was just kind of a little
wake-up call right
yeah okay yeah it was definitely
something strange and new for me
just going through that and seeing well
i'm i'm
really out of my depth and but yeah you
learn so much more if i if i would have
gone with what i know i definitely would
have taken that
um and that happened so many times last
in the last two years
where i've just said yes to things and
and then realize like what what am i
doing i have no
clue what i'm doing i sold myself and
and i
i got the job but now what right now i'm
i'm
i'm
getting nervous and anxious and and but
then
you realize like just take one step at a
time and
it's incredible what you can do and what
you can learn while you're doing it yep
and it's a lot better than if you learn
it by
things watching someone else do it first
and then you do it right
it's you're doing on-the-job training
while getting paid which is the best way
to do it
so i have so many questions just on this
one story alone
how did you know how much to charge and
did you feel at that time
when you submitted the number that it
was going to be too much or am i worth
it
do you go through that whole process
that many creative people do
definitely do yes so the um the hardest
part is
is knowing are you pitching in too low
or too high
right and if you're if you're too low
like you know the answer you're gonna
get
is like yes we'll take it uh it's like
they they won't wait for the reply they
don't even have to ask their supervisors
for yes
um you know it's it's good
or you're maximizing out what you're
getting when
when they are like i'll have to talk and
i have to do
and you know you've pitched too high
when when's the clear no it's like sorry
we cannot afford that
right and and it's interesting like i've
always seen the
the the pricing uh system as
there are people who are willing to pay
for something like
if you're rich then you don't care about
money that much like
value is something that is what is value
to you
and and i've seen that in the wedding
photography industry i've i've been a
wedding photographer before
and and i've learned so much because you
can sell yourself as a wedding
photographer for fifteen thousand
a day or for two thousands a lot of
people will opt for two thousand because
they'll get jobs for two thousand
but there are people who are willing to
pay fifteen grand for a wedding
photographer
or more and it doesn't mean they're any
they're anything better
they're just they're able to find
clients that are willing to pay that
much and who value
their work for that much and so i've
seen that for myself as well as a
lettering artist like
for some people like if if i would
design your tattoo for two thousand
bucks it's like it's
that's insane i would not pay that for
myself um
and like i wouldn't pay necessarily my
prices for myself but for other people
for clients like
bigger corporation that's the value that
you have for them like for coca-cola
um a post on instagram and and something
that they can use on times square like
that's that has value to them
and a lot more than maybe the the
startup that is just starting out
and so when i go into pricing and
especially here for the for the airport
project it was something i've never done
before
and it's it's usually asking a lot of
questions in the beginning asking
everything you can to figure out what
you are um like what you're getting
yourself into
and then also set the presses right that
they don't cannot add
work without you just like oh i didn't
know about that now i have to do that
too so that's kind of how the price grew
it doubled
actually in budget because um
she didn't know half of the the the
formats
that will be used like there were all of
these videos that would be used there
was this mega post that would come in
there are all these different canvas
sizes that they wanted and my design
luckily for me was not flexible in
in the in the format so because words
were drawn everywhere and they didn't
want to cut
out words so it ended up like
we'll have to scale it and you have to
draw in additional words if you see the
piece
is somewhere on my instagram and
definitely on my homepage
it's it's it's nice because like that
format didn't apply to anything and
you had a little bit of wiggle room but
not that much and so
i had to redraw every format and that's
how my budget increased over time
but when i put out i just went through
the steps like how much
like administration fees like the the
email back and forth will be huge on
on to this project so i want to make
sure that that's kind of covered
um all the sketches that i'm doing how
many revisions round do i
do i want to make and how many like how
how much am i comfortable with
doing something and and so forth and
that has
helped me um figure out the price and
kind of
go back and forth with them and then in
the end it was more like
buyout rights um that was a huge part
like it's it's something i as as someone
who has not
studied design or or or worked in an
agency or something like that
um buyout rides is something very
strange
and where you didn't know that there is
actually money to be made where you can
actually set it off
and so now they can use that campaign
every every year
and i'm not getting a penny for that
because they bought the rides
but for the project i got a lot so right
it's it is out somewhere
you factored in the usage as part of
your price so
do you have a rule of thumb in terms of
here's the base price and if they ask
for a global buyout
i mean they pretty much own it to work
for a higher at that point
then is there a percentage that you'd
like to go with and ask for on top of
the base fee
um so i did because i knew it was
national they didn't want international
they just wanted like unlimited uh
amount of time
and then i i just looked over the price
and and looked kind of what feels right
if i asked double the price like triple
the price
um like multiplied by two
and and said like that's that's the
additional for the buyout then i i just
felt like looking at the number
um i just didn't feel right about it so
i'm
i i could say i'm a very emotional
pricing person
um i i'm going after what feels right
and
how do i if i'm the client how do i look
at the number and can justify that or
not
and and so all the buyouts on this
project were about
like a 50 or 100 of the design work
on top of that and and then and that's
where we
we had discussion room where like can
you reduce or can we do the full buyout
for
this set price and not like add on top
and so at the end
i i actually had to cut budget from
from the buyout but like the whole
design price was was included
and at the end i still felt great about
it
it's just more that as soon as you have
a number set in your head you're like
you kind of want to see that
number come in but at the end it was
like well
we have discussed that here and here and
here and here and and so
there was a little bit of back and forth
and since i valued
the work that i was able to do for them
i valued them
um i i was like happy to to cut off a
little
chunk of of the buyout in the end
i have to ask you this question it's not
for me but it's from our audience who
are going to be watching this
and either live or later on they're
going to say
but wait a minute do you feel guilty
for charging a client who could afford
more more for the work
than a client who could afford less
isn't that unethical
i don't feel this way but i'm gonna ask
you to see how you respond
yeah i i know you don't feel this way i
don't feel this way either it's um
it's it's a good question to ask it's
you
you feel like like can i
like can i change my prices and like
they're they're companies who who your
work for them is more valuable for them
than it is for a startup
um you said that in in a uh in your
probably most popular video it's like
if i do a logo for coca-cola like that
logo will be everywhere on every bottle
everything
and so messing that up is is a
huge part of the deal um and so there's
a risk involved as well
and in talking about like wedding
photography
like i would say like there's you
definitely have a chance to mess things
up
but uh both people will do a work and
about similar in in like in design like
same thing like you buy a rolex or you
buy a
a super expensive watch like i don't
i don't tell you you have to buy that
like if if i would tell you you need to
buy like if it's water
it's something that you need to live and
i would price it just higher for you
than for someone else that would that
would be unethical
but if it's a product that you can
choose from um you don't
have to work with me if you want to work
with me that's my price
and so that's where i feel um
you can change that around and and still
for me it's it's it's
about how do i feel about the price and
like for the project for coca-cola i
didn't actually pitch the price
i asked for their budget um when i was
on the phone with them and they just
said like this is our budget
and and funny enough i would have i
would have gone below that way below
that
and and the best part is when they came
back with me to with their
their contract i was reading through it
and it's like you know what
i should ask for more and and even
though i
i i had a really great deal i just
wanted to take that
and uh i just i just saw that suddenly
they they asked what they were asking me
for
was was everything plus they had the
rights to to use the picture in any way
they want so
right i feel when it comes to pricing
asking the person
as many questions as you can like why
are you including this in the contract
why
are why do you want this right why do
you want to have
exclusive right for everything um why do
i have to
have an exclusivity um like
clause in in the contract and so
um this is something that i that i've
seen um
helped me a lot hold on hold on
something happened jonah what are you
doing
it exited out for whatever reason did we
lose
no we're though we're there we're still
there yeah jonah trying to show people's
secret emails
or something like jonas
we're trying to figure out your
coca-cola client right now so don't
worry don't worry we're hacking you this
inside um
yeah but but exactly for that like um
only through asking
questions i realized that they wanted to
put that ad or to put that
design on time square and thanks to that
i
i was able to like all right well you
know if you want to put that on times
square that's worth something
um so i asked for more and we found ours
together in like halfway and
and so it's like it's it's kind of
stupid if you're asking for more money
for something that you're already
getting more than you thought you would
get
but at the same time it's like it's also
just basic uh
negotiating skills it's like trying to
get the best deal you can
for yourself and and then you
as as a as a designer as the creative
like how can you give your client the
best value for what they paid for
um so it goes both ways it's like it's
unethical if you think about
like i'm just getting more and i don't
have to do like you don't have to do
more your design work is not going to
improve by that much
but it's it's like how can i like do my
best on this project and
and be the best client or best creative
they've ever hired
and and so that's a relationship you're
going to start building
right okay we got a lot of questions
coming in i just want to say
hello to everybody especially people
tuning in from nigeria some people are
saying like i'm up really late 10 24 boo
hoo 10 24 is not up really late come on
come on if you can't stay up late late
to watch this channel and get some
information from stuff on to see how
this guy
who i believe is self-taught and
somewhat new to the the world of design
how he's able to charge
not just thousands but tens of thousands
for his work and he's sharing very
openly so i do appreciate that
okay so you said you have not been doing
this for very long and you have not gone
to school for this what the heck did you
go to school for and how that
how does one become stefan and be such
an amazing artist and lettering
so give us the secret man what's up so
i was always interested in design and i
love designing
um yeah like just drawing doing creative
stuff
i i did first to start out with
photography uh with
videography then went into photography
and then
um like i had a job in banking so that's
kind of what i learned like i have a
diploma in banking so swiss banker
is that what all the kids study in
switzerland like banking
well you pretty much think so but it
does feel like that
it's it's it's a huge uh job in
switzerland
um but it i learned so much from
from that just doing uh banking just
learning on the job like
client interaction like being a teller
just um like
taking people money in giving them money
out
having that one working with like
high net worth clients and and then
talking about their finances
how like how they invest their money
it's very very
interesting um trying to sell people
credit cards like
one one of the the things you have to do
as a banker is like
either sell them on funds or
or credit cards and but the first lesson
you'll learn is like
don't sell them anything they don't want
like if if they're not going to be happy
with it then you're just selling them
something bad and and even if your
corporation requires you to get some
numbers um
you will always be better off selling
them things that they want
and that you can help them with and not
something that
like it's not going to be useful for
them so that's kind of the first thing
that i've learned there
and i've applied to you to whatever i do
like i'm not gonna sell you
anything you don't want and i'm gonna
try to like if it's not a fit between
the client and me i'm not gonna take it
like it's
it's i'm better off not taking what's um
what they don't want and i think you
said that too it's
if i can find someone better for the job
then or like if they come back with
preferences of of
some of my friends i i won't take the
job because i'm like
just ask that person they'll do this job
that you want
um and so it's you're better off that
way
and you learn so much from from
different from different jobs
like i've learned so much from banking
i've learned so much from wedding
photography
um from from different industries that i
just been into
and and that has helped me be
the person who i am today and doing
business the way i do it today
and yeah well let's let's enough about
the banking already swiss boy you
how about the lettering how did you
learn to do the lettering stuff
so that was really funny i one day i
just looked over my instagram
um it was a pier where i was sick for
for a couple of months i was laid off
from
work for two months um and
and i looked over my instagram and i
just saw like this is just random
stuff that i'm posting and there's
nothing there
so one day i decided like all right
let's let's change that let's actually
post something
like more consistent more with value um
and at the time my value was not that
much but it's it's like i i posted a
picture of
a lego reindeer like those miniature
legos
and and like had a an app that would
have
have like these graphic templates that
you can just put over and you just have
to change the text
and and added that into um into my
iphone
and then it grew into like i use an app
called over use that for text editing
and and creating
and and then it kindly like gradually
evolved into two more steps
um to suddenly where this app couldn't
allow me to to
improve anymore so i was stuck with what
the app allowed me to do i've used every
function that they
that they enabled me to do and so i
decided to start drawing
and that was 2014 and i had no idea that
lettering was
one was a job and was something that
people did for a living
and i just did it and and my account
grew a little bit like it was
at a thousand um but then i
i i was always very competitive so a
friend of mine
was always a little bit ahead of me and
he was in photography
a really good photographer and so i i
didn't tell him but i was shadowing him
or trying to beat him just
a couple followers more than he had and
when i met him
um here in australia actually i i told
him you know what i'm
always trying to beat you and always be
ahead like a couple of followers like 10
followers ahead of you
and so he said like why not do a game
out of this like let's see who gets to 5
000 first and for me that was like
well from one and a half thousand to
five thousand that's
a major step and and so
but i was like challenge taken i'm on
and i'll beat you
um and and so he had like he was married
he was doing us
he was studying he was working on the
side and it's like
i'm i'm single i have a banking job that
doesn't
use so much of my my um my time or like
energy
so i have a lot of energy and i have
time to do that
and so i was racing and in one month or
so i had
grown from one one and a half thousand
to five thousands
and then it was another slow slow time
to ten
fifteen thousands i started a a
challenge called the hundred day
creative challenge where it's like every
day
doing something with type and so i
decided back then like all right
typography is my thing that's what i'm
going to stick with
um and at the time i really didn't want
to do any client work i didn't want to
do that as a job
because i just didn't know how to do
client work right
and i always had this problem that i
sold my my
my project as as a full project
not on a narrowly great and and so and i
just said like
feel kind of like a client satisfaction
and and when they came back with
revisions and random
revisions and if you don't say that
clearly like you have two rounds of
revisions
um then they'll come back and their
communication will
will degrade and because they're just
like oh i can send him an email now and
and then if i find something else i'll
can send that again
and so i hated that part uh until i i
saw some other designers that i wanted
to hire to create a logo for me
i saw i read to their um their contracts
and their agreements
and i thought that was clearly stated
like you have two revision rounds
and that helped me so much in that space
to
to grow and to to go forward so um
when i heard that i actually changed
that around and suddenly client work
became easier and a lot uh
better and at the same time i was like
growing my instagram
um i had it around 20 25 thousands
um because i was pumping out work every
day
and so a lot of people were talking
about my challenge that i was doing
they were like oh you should check out
this guy like he's doing this 100 day
creative challenge
um and and then at the beginning of the
year i saw
i saw that
that my account was growing about 200
followers a day
and and so that moment i did what uh
every banker does is like open
spreadsheets and
like count down like how much like how
much
followers would you accumulate over a
year every day if you gain 200 a day
so i learned that around 20 30 000 at
the end of the year you would reach
a hundred thousand so suddenly this was
a huge
milestone that i envisioned and i'm like
i have a goal now
that's what i want to reach and to
achieve that i had to get better with
with what i did with what i created so
growing on instagram meant also
growing my skills and that helped kind
of build that
uh milestone and so ever since it was
always like
i gotta get better with what i do
because i gotta
like i gotta impress people i gotta keep
people interested and not leaving
like if i do the same thing over and
over again like i can grow fast for one
time but not grow
uh continually and i've grown pretty
much every year since then like a
hundred thousand
i've always hit the hundred thousand
mark um
ever since wow and this year i'm way
ahead of the crew
beautiful look there's somebody in our
chat right now her name is
janna virey and she says i've been
following staphon for a while now and
i'm so proud to see how far he's come
also my two worlds are colliding is the
dream stephon in the future i believe
okay so matthew this is awesome matthew
some questions maybe
yeah there's there's a lot of questions
i'm going to pull them up but i want to
make a
interesting observation about stefan
what i've heard and just hearing your
story
the thing that i like about you and and
i can relate to this a little bit is
that
it seems like you just put yourself into
new situations and you're a sponge
so whatever situation you go in you look
and you're curious you're observant
and you learn from that very quickly and
you apply it very quickly so i think
that's why over three years you're able
to grow
so quickly both on your instagram and
your
how much you're charging professionally
like how you practice
seems like you're able to take all these
different things because you have that
open mind that curiosity
and you're willing to apply it right
away without hesitation so
i want to say kudos to you for that
because that's very amazing thank you
yeah also what's up denmark what's up
canada i was gonna say toronto but it's
not toronto like
uh okay uh matthew what are the
questions so there's one here from
kristen mcmaster and she asked my
question for stefan is
did you have nice handwriting growing up
oh that's a good one
come on he switches
that is a common um thing that people
think about
yeah i actually did have a nice
handwriting so i love
handwriting and i love writing but that
has nothing to do with lettering
so that's it it's kind of bad that i
actually do have a nice handwriting
but a lot of my friends who are letting
artists they don't have a nice
handwriting
that's the thing why doctors have a bad
handwriting is because they don't like
apply themselves and they they just
write really really fast
and if i if i would write really really
fast i wouldn't have that much
like it would still be legible but it
would still be
like it would be more wonky and
i think that's a big misconception
though uh nevertheless
um that's yeah that people who do
lettering have a nice hand in writing
of course i know how to to draw like a
beautiful
s and i can apply that into you to
whatever i write and do it easy
and like make it look effortlessly but
that comes through a lot of practice as
well
well i gotta ask you this question since
you learned how to do hand lettering
and you're very good at it now do you go
back and write notes with the same kind
of precision or is there a
i'm in lettering artist mindset and then
there's i'm just a regular dude i'm just
going to write this real quick
so definitely so when i take notes um
like let me just hold up your notepad
yeah let's do this
let's put this issue to bed it's like
everybody thinks oh you're a graphic
designer you must be able to draw
and lettering i think is like a learned
skill that you draw forms and you you're
good at drafting
and if you're good at drawing cards it
doesn't mean you have a nice hand
lettering
just because you're good at figurative
drawing doesn't mean you're good you
have good hand
we can't really see can you guys see
that okay yeah yeah that's pretty good
that's pretty clean
yeah but it's not like his chalkboard
drawings no it's not
crazy no it's definitely not definitely
not and
and like i can apply myself it's it's
always a question of how much time do
you have right
and you really want to do it like like
the poster um
you guys have in the background with the
what sleeper but
um yeah but not a heavy dreamer like if
if i would if i would draw that d like
that
like i can do that but it's easier to
draw a d
like when you're writing something like
if i would be writing dreaming like
i wouldn't write that d in that same
style right just takes up too much time
so there's one i guess it's really
around the intent
am i am i making a piece of art or am i
just communicating and i just need to
get my notes down
that's really all it is right to capture
my thoughts so okay good
so hello malaysia what did what other
kind of questions we got matthew
there's a bunch of questions uh circling
process
and i was wondering maybe if you could
walk us through that because people are
asking
do you start analog or digital how do
you come up with your concepts
and um you know like how where do you
begin and maybe if you could eliminate
some of those steps
the good old process question yeah
all right so the good old process
question starts definitely that
my process changes every time um
if my process would stay the same i
definitely
i feel like it would be easier just to
have like a formula
but what i've realized it's it's graphic
design designing in general it's always
about
problem solving so you always like like
you start off with
like how can i design this quote or how
can i design like what what does the
client want and or what do i want to
create
and how do i start and and then you
start off with ideas like you you pitch
them down you write them down
and whatever is easiest for you it's
like usually it's
pen on paper sometimes it's even uh it's
drawing on the ipad
whatever you have around you that's kind
of what you get and i like to switch
around between ipad between paper
sketchbooks and all that and then i
but mostly before even i start doing
that
i i often think about how in my head how
i can
visualize it so i'm a very visual person
so i'll
always visualize how it will look in
real life
and how can does does that actually work
like that piece that you're just showing
there that together
um like i already saw the people
standing in there
like the the people around and with the
shadow i didn't know about the design
how far it would go but i kind of saw
the person and so i'm like all right the
circle
is important how can i do that and and
how can i mix that up
and and and then for that one i
yeah i the story behind this one is
actually really funny i
i was procrastinating all day long till
about 3 p.m
and um the sun was setting about 4 5 p.m
and i and i wanted to go for a run and
or
or do something like like active and
then finally ended up like
sitting down and starting sketching this
out and and i
like i was already in in the zone and i
kept on going and suddenly i realized
like all right now it's too late to go
out
i just keep on going and i procrastinate
all day long and then
suddenly like start working on this
piece and and work till
like from 3 p.m till 4 p.m in the
morning
and really when i was exhausted i
i just like all right i gotta stop here
because i'm not making any progress
anymore i'm just
circling around i'm not happy with the
colors i'm not happy with how it looks
and like i've missed my posting time and
that's
kind of the instagram way of saying i've
missed my deadline
so i'm gonna go to the next deadline um
and so i i slept a couple of hours
woke up again and then kept on working
and then trying out different colors
um and then yeah then asked all my my
followers for
for pictures of of their feet so those
are actually
a picture of my followers feet um to
bring it all together and and that's
kind of a cool
integration with your community how to
get your community to engage with you
so there are like um four or five people
and then there's like
one uh top left is this uh photo of a
like from unsplash um that i use as well
but yes so so you start um
visualizing everything in your head and
you start thinking of how can you bring
that together
but then you're sketching out and then
comes like then the path
actually starts to change because what
you think was like oh i'm just going
from a to b
suddenly becomes like a divergent and
you
circle around things you go there and
like you sketch this out um you have
different options and then you just
choose like which one is the best option
that i can
go on with like if if you're working for
client it's definitely going to be him
deciding whether or not which piece he
wants to keep on going
right and the process keeps on changing
and for example the last piece of chalk
that i did the
home is where the pants aren't there
it's like i wanted to do something on
the chalk wall
um and start off with the like home is
where the chalk wall is
then moved into like home is where the
pants aren't uh because
it was just funny of i i had that idea
of like holding the the pants up
and making that an egg that was a
perfect shape for it and then when i was
starting designing i'm like i have no
idea like composition wise how to make
it interesting
and and so i just drew these two lines
like the upper
and and lower line of the pants and and
kind of that slanted
um that up slanted line and that became
like the
the center and then then becomes like
that problem-solving
um okay where do i put the next words
and like uh is where bounces out
beautifully
um and so you go from there and you you
just keep on going and then
suddenly it turned out like i think it
turned out great
there's a lot of things that would
change uh like they aren't
i would change that um it's it's not as
nice
or not as structured as the home um so i
might have changed
the style of aren't into the same style
that were
and and stuff like that and definitely
the inside of the pants
is is something that i've still been
working on who took that photo for you
um my housemate did okay so you have
somebody that documents you while you do
your work
well no i while i'm working i definitely
have like a camera that just films me
i just have a tripod that i use um but
when i um when i
when i finish the work if if there's
someone around i'll definitely
um use use that person
uh but if i have no one around i'll just
use a tripod and a timer like i said
there's some that i did with with the uh
with the phone as a trigger
so you have like an app that you can
connect to your camera and then you
should
just use it to figure out and he did all
of this in his
boxers without him without that you
should have done a naked dude come on
you're just playing it too safe yeah
it's no pants that's
there's still some pants i know it i but
it's still it's
it's like the if if we're talking about
like how to grow on
on instagram and like something like how
can you get people to talk about you
right um i love the the the podcast you
do with
um uh what's his name from
johnny cupcakes um like doing something
that people will
talk about that have like like that's
how you
how people will like you'll get further
and
people will recommend you and and
they're like oh did you see this guy who
did a time lapse of him drawing
something in in his underwear
right like and at the beginning i tried
to make it um
because you always want to start the
engagement on your post
with with like a lot of hype so it has
to take off strong
otherwise it might get lost in in the
algorithm
the magical algorithm that we're all so
worried about
um and and so i did what i did it was
i asked people like oh i i kind of
forgot to put on pants for this one
and kind of like make it look like a
mistake until they see the quotes
right um and so so people were already
like
messaging me like what did you really
forget it and they're like laughing
and everything i see that creates that
chris the hype of you like oh actually i
want to see that
look at him yeah
yeah well that's very interesting
because you took a familiar phrase which
is home is where the heart is
you put one twist in it and you figure
out how can you build interest in it
you can call it hype you can call
whatever pr marketing but there you are
you're really smart about this kind of
stuff dang i still hate you
all right let's see what else here right
it wasn't
it wasn't my quote i pinterest helped a
lot with that one
we're doing a challenge for lauren hum
and and the challenge was like all right
using a phrase that that everyone can
use in the challenge but that everyone
can adapt so this one is
home is where and then i'll ask people
to
to use that to to do something creative
and and so that's kind of been the gist
of it but i've seen i've seen the home
is where
the pants aren't is is i've seen that
many times
on on pinterest okay and so i'm just
taking that
i got a couple of quick questions for
you so hopefully because i'm looking at
the time here mindful of the time we're
we're kind of at the hour mark here so
i want to get as many questions in as
possible so you have to do the erin
draplin challenges which is the answer
pretty quickly
okay i got a couple of quick questions
for you how long did it take you to do
that piece
where home is where the pants are two
and a half hours wow
and is that just chalk you're using or
using one of those liquid chalk markers
regular chalk regular chalk crayola
all right okay the other piece
where you were talking about together
you're breaking my heart here because
i thought that was a real piece you're
telling me that photoshop dude
there's nothing real on the internet oh
my god and that was like
wow the feet in the shadows yeah the
lighting looked painted
he hired some tile making person and
some
artisan crafting this together you're
like no it's photoshop dude
wow that would be amazing it would take
a lot longer doing that in real life
doing that on photoshop
definitely took me like it took me like
19 hours to actually draw that and then
i i hand clicked in the colors for every
tile
so that's a lot of clicking you're still
breaking my heart man
okay matthew you got some quick
questions for him um
man i don't know about okay i got one
then yeah go ahead uh how do you get
clients there we go there it is that
that is a brilliant question and
i at the same time i still don't know
exactly how i get clients
um i love to tell you like these are the
steps you have to take
um and i'm get i'm not like
i'm a faith person and so i believe in
god
and i i've had the the privilege that
like i've dreamed a lot of big dreams
like the thing for coca-cola
and at across times square and and last
year just like it blew my mind
and and for me it's always been that i
had an agent for a while i
had someone who was representing me and
and what i
always got back from them was you know
what we're trying
like we've reached out to clients and
somehow like no one comes back and asks
like wants to work with you or it's it's
hard to say it's like
i've had the most amazing opportunity to
just drop into my inbox
and and coming in and and at the same
time like
there are a lot of things that i love to
do and love to reach out to for example
do
like the chalk well you could do so many
fun cool
uh paid promotions with that like for my
undies would that would have been great
for my undies for you realize
um but there's like a quote that is um
abs are
great but have you tried donuts and so i
have this picture of me sitting at the
bottom
with like a krispy kreme or a or a
donuts
box and then having the whole room
filled with donuts like
a scrooge mcduck kind of the style and
have that quote in the background and so
it's kind of like it's a great platform
or a great way to advertise
but i've always had trouble to how to
communicate that because if i did it
it's hard to do it again if like if i
write on a samsung
um luggage like it's it's great if i get
them so continue to work with me
um but it's hard to do that in advance
before you've actually done it
and and so these are were like kind of
difficult things
that i had to to deal with but like the
the airport
project coca-cola asics and and all
these companies like it's usually been
someone who's either been following me
or or found me or been recommended to
and and so on but what i'm trying to do
now
strongly is is client retention like
we've always heard that client retention
is so much easier
than client acquisition and and talking
about
um clients like i try to like like
keep working with the the clients that i
love to work with and like for example
the project we're seeing now with
bombay sapphire that was in berlin i was
an
amazing project i worked with an amazing
team and and i just want to work with
those people again
so so i like the people that i love to
work with like
i i'm going to reach out to them and
just offering my help and saying like
hey how can i help you do whatever you
need to do like if there's something
that i can help you with let me help you
i'm glad you asked well you could paint
a mirror at our place
no i'm just messing around with you okay
so i like your attitude look
i want i want to pin you down a little
bit here people ask
how do you get clients he's like he gave
us a long story about weird answers like
maybe you're not aware of what it is
that you're doing but i'm picking up on
your secret what i've heard so far
in two of the examples or three of the
examples that you gave which is
i don't think you take instagram like
how most people take instagram
i think you sit there and you think like
what am i gonna do that's going to get
people to talk about and you're
conceptually designing it
almost like an ad an ad in a way that's
really engaging the way that you talked
about donuts and
you know abs are nice but donuts are
better or whatever it is that you said
and you're thinking about how to frame
that and shoot it the same thing with
your
pants how to create a little bit of fun
controversy
and the tiles on the floor and getting
people involved in the community
it's almost like you're a social media
marketing person
who just so happens to be a pretty darn
good hand lettering artist just on the
side
you know what i mean matthew like he
takes it seriously and
and so there's everybody that's out
there like oh there's all these young
talentless like hacks out there and
they're just growing their thing
no because they take it really seriously
right you basically just
put the entire future team on notice
right now hell
i know you're watching this now see the
level in which people are racing to like
that's how serious we have to
we have been campaigns so really stefan
i don't even know if this is your true
calling maybe when you're back in zurich
and maybe you and i talk a little bit
and it could be your coach or something
maybe you should sell the service of i'm
going to help you design
campaigns and we're going to charge you
250
and uncle chris will only take 10
percent i'm very generous that way
and then you get to sit there and use
that creative brand of yours to think
like
we'll shoot it this way and you just art
direct and creative direct the whole
thing
who knows reach out to me afterwards i
think stefan is the uh the
johnny cupcakes of the handwritten world
he is he's a master marketer
very very smart yeah intelligent god i
hate you
dang unorthodox marketing over here yes
well no actually it is
orthodox marketing just applied to
platforms where people just
are too lazy to think about it that way
right so these guys
especially stefan is just like really
into it and he can figure this thing out
dang i think you need to make a course
and seller in the future about how to be
a master marketer
on instagram let's just do it
let's do it right yeah i got to say yes
this is great
and we'll be sitting there on scrooge
mcduck count in the millions like oh my
gosh this is so good
all right matthew um it's almost time
for us to end the show i have my notes
already but
i want to give you because the you know
the gentleman that i am matthew i'm
going to give you the opportunity to ask
the last question
oh what is it going to be man okay i got
it
i do i i mean i we've unpacked a lot on
this very short live stream and i think
we've
here at the end uncovered some of the
genius behind
some of the stuff that you do if you
were to give advice for somebody who
wants to
start doing this what one tip would you
give them
there it is help them along the way one
tip i want you to think about this one
is that one good solid amazing golden
nugget
right at the end here it's it's actually
a really really simple one
and i wish nike didn't steal it from me
no
it's it's really just do it like you're
we have so many excuses of doing
something and we're waiting for a sign
from heaven to drop
to to come and and like my my quote is
or that i use a lot is create something
today even if it sucks
because we we wait till we are good or
we we have an excuse for everything we
have an excuse for
not being perfect for not having enough
time
for uh all these things and that's like
that's exactly what i
i do at conferences like i try to tell
people like just
do it make it happen like even if you
have to write it on a toilet paper
like it's it's it's like there's no
excuse like even if you have to draw it
on toilet or
or wherever just do it and
and i'm i'm the best example of where it
can get you
like if you just start if you have no
idea if you have no degree
and and just do what you can over time
you'll get better you'll get so good
and and so good that the world cannot
ignore you anymore
and and so that's where if you're
waiting for something to happen
then you're just waiting and you're not
doing and if you're doing then you
can't imagine where it can bring you
like i never thought i would have a
ad on times square like i think like not
in the next 10 years
but somehow it did happen and you never
know what's
like what crazy things can happen fan
tests all right okay
i got the summary here here we go before
we say goodbye to stefan here we go
here's my summary
summary first of all we've learned in a
very short period of time i think only a
few years apparently a few years
steven's gone from
doing client work and doing products and
and passive income and courses
that has superseded his ability to even
do client work he also gets paid by
doing ig post because he's an influencer
he gets paid he gets paid to speak and
now he's venturing into coaching so if
you guys want to reach out to
stefan after this do so he's a coach and
i'm going to tell you a couple other
things
that i learned one is that he has a
minimum it's important to understand
your minimum
regardless of how quickly he can get a
job done if a client is willing to pay
him three thousand dollars for
ten minutes of work no problem just pay
me the three grand i'm good with that i
like that
and he's like think about usage rights
and negotiate for that
and it's got to feel right for you and
the client and so it's probably a
conversation
but it's a way to tap into some higher
billings
higher estimates that you can do ask a
lot of questions to help define the
scope of the project
because that's when the scope can
mushroom and then therefore
you you need to think about the entirety
of the project and can actually build
more for it
pricing is a bit of an art form i think
there's more to it but his philosophy
is if they say yes too quick there's a
good chance your pricing too
low and if they give you that hard no
like oh my god forget about it
maybe you went too high and through
asking questions you're gonna get a
feeling for it
and if they have to push back a little
bit get approval him and haul a little
bit
chances are you find the right price you
found the ceiling
and just as a good tip sometimes you can
just ask the clients
what's your budget for this what have
you spent historically for something
like this you could have asked the
airport the same thing
and most people are very ethical and
they will just tell you last year we
spent this
and then you can go from there you can
say you know that's a little low from
what we just talked about
but at least you have a baseline it's
good to know and it is not a sequence
but he said be so good the world can't
ignore you
if we could all live by that philosophy
the world would be a view to full place
okay next up these are the funny notes i
have be a bank teller so you can get
used to taking people's money
that's the job i wish i had but i was
busy being a stock boy at a supermarket
not the proper training on how to be a
business and a creative entrepreneur
here's a business hack i'm not saying he
said it like this but this is how i
heard it
ask another design firm to show you
their bid so you can see how they
structure their project
and then copy it that's how he's doing
that's a business hack right there just
look at how other professionals
are defining the engagement and see what
you can learn from it
here's the thing that i really really
learned this is my one key takeaway is
to treat your instagram account
like a creative challenge to get people
to pay attention
don't just like post something because
it's convenient be creative and think
about campaigns
and how you can get engagement and his
last little bit of advice of course nike
stole
way ahead of time is just do it stop
thinking about just go out there and
make it stephen coons was on the show
he is at typox photo.com
and you can also check him out on
youtube he's got a channel here
i think 30 some odd thousand subscribers
on his youtube channel
and he makes tools for creative fools
just like you whatever i'm trying to
rhyme guys give me
give me a little slack here this episode
was brought to you by the typeface well
hand lettering goodness by stefan
himself and knockout you guys thanks
very much for tuning in
be sure to like comment and subscribe
and hit that bell we love you
thank you for being a sustaining member
peace guys see you later